est-ce que c'est pas très grave et très
triste de voir quelqu'un comme vous
aujourd'hui
se radicaliser à ce point-là non ce
n'est pas
radicaliser il y a certaines vérités
égyptien
monument national en Égypte au même
titre que les pyramides
on va voir un petit peu ce que vous avez
fait dans votre vie et ce que vous
pensez aujourd'hui vous avez été acteur
c'était votre première vocation vous
êtes scénariste vous êtes réalisateur
vous êtes metteur en scène et
compositeur puisque vous avez fait la
bande sans du film de vous qui sort en
ce moment si l'on s'entourne
je vais faire le pitch du film je vais
raconter l'histoire si vous voulez
Youssef toutes les soins non et ils vont
pas aller voir le film
ok bien alors l'histoire c'est
l'histoire de Malak qui est une riche
cantatrice et actrice entièrement dévoué
à son art surproé comme beaucoup de
stars par son entourage et elle est
seule elle est d'autant plus celle que
son mari vient de la quitter elle veut
un homme cette femme vulnérable et donc
la proie idéale pour un dénommé la Mei
un arriviste qui n'en veut qu'à sa
fortune
elle tombe dans le panneau
elle vit une passion obsessionnelle avec
ce lamelle elle se met en péril mais
heureusement le scénariste et le metteur
en scène imagine un tas de stratagèmes
qui révéleront à Malak la convoitise de
l'abeille ce qui est extraordinaire du
sept Shane c'est que cette histoire
dramatique au départ vous la traiter sur
un mode léger avec beaucoup d'ironie
beaucoup de sketchs des trucages à la
Tex Avery vous empruntez même un moment
une scène à lubitch une scène de La
Veuve Joyeuse en noir et blanc
et c'est là vous êtes un vrai
professionnel c'est à dire que
finalement vous êtes capable de prendre
une histoire et de la traiter dans un
genre complètement différent dans votre
vie vous avez fait des films historiques
vous avez fait des films
autobiographiques vous avez fait des
comédies mais quel que soit le film que
vous fassiez il y a toujours dedans la
dénonciation c'est le point commun
finalement qu'on peut trouver dans toute
votre œuvre
quand on vit dans un contexte qui est
tellement tordu
ok c'est dangereux de le dire mais
il faut il faut je crois que c'est un
devoir parce que la nouvelle jeunesse
moi je vois pas la traiter comme les
américains traitent leur jeunesse qui
n'ont qu'une qui ne voit qu'un seul
point de vue le pays le plus riche du
monde avec les meilleurs universités et
bien il a les jeunes les plus ignorants
au monde qui nous voit que ce point de
vue celui de Hollywood donc si l'on
s'entourne vous dénoncez cette fois à
travers l'arriviste lamelle vous
dénoncez un nouveau personnage qui a
fait son apparition dans la société
égyptienne c'est l'homme d'affaires
cette dénonciation de l'homme d'affaires
vous l'élargissez à une critique de la
mondialisation et au pourrissement par
l'argent
c'est le thème
moi j'ai dit le type qui fait des
chaussures c'est des chaussures le
metteur en scène fait des films celui
qui fait des cellules le serrurier
l'homme d'affaires c'est quoi des
affaires qu'est-ce que c'est que les
affaires attention les affaires c'est
les affaires
c'est votre 37e film Youssef Chahin vous
avez 75 ans vous êtes né en 1926 à
Alexandra
alors c'est vrai il est forte
quand on se remémore Alexandrie à
l'époque fois que vous êtes né pendant
toute votre jeunesse c'était une espèce
de paradis Alexandrie c'était la
capitale du cosmopolitisme une ville de
culture et de tolérance il y avait 17
nationalités on parlait cinq langues il
y avait des Maltais il y avait des Grecs
il y avait des Italiens il y avait des
Arméniens et surtout une cohabitation
parfaite entre les Juifs et les Arabes
ah oui parce que on n'a jamais on sait
jamais posé cette question tu cours on
s'en fout comment elle pris si elle est
jolie elle est jolie quoi
c'est très important parce que vous avez
connu cette espèce de jardin d'Eden
avant la pomme alors vous étiez
catholique vous êtes catholique
d'ailleurs votre père d'origine
libanaise le vantin comme on disait à
l'époque avocat établi à Alexandrie
votre mère est d'origine grecque et
syrienne de migraine vous êtes élevé
dans l'école catholique et puis vous
allez au prestigieux Victoria collège ou
aller toute la gentry de d'Alexandrie et
rapidement vous êtes influencé par
l'opérette française il faut savoir que
Youssef Chahine a été influencé par
Henri Garat avoir un bon copain par
Milton j'ai la rade qui se dilate et
puis par le cinéma américain ouais à 14
ans Youssef Chahine donc dans sa bonne
ville d'Alexandrie rêve de comme Jean
Kelly et d'ailleurs après un an
d'université Alexandrie vous partez à
Los Angeles pour apprendre pour voir
comment ça se passe pour apprendre le
métier d'acteur pour voir comment on
réalise des films et quand vous revenez
au Caire vous rentrez rapidement dans le
milieu du cinéma kairote qui à l'époque
est très florissant et vous commencez à
faire des films voilà alors je dis ça
parce que voilà c'est les deux Eden
disparus de Youssef Chahin c'est-à-dire
d'une part Alexandrie cette ville où
tout le monde s'entendait bien ou toutes
les espèces de Babel réussi ou toutes
les communautés s'entendaient bien et
puis les Américains l'Amérique pays du
rêve non non non tant que sa vie
dans mon cœur à moi en tout cas étant
que je fais des films je continue à
envoyer Alexandrie aux autres en tous
les cas Alexandrie ben ça commence à
aller mal quand quand on Acer le De
Gaulle arabe
signe un petit peu la fin de ce monde en
nationalisant le canal de Suez ce qui
était une très bonne chose mais c'est
vrai à ce moment-là beaucoup de gens
s'en vont avec sandrie beaucoup
d'étrangers quitte Alexandrie à ce
moment-là
tous les copains qu'on attendait à ce
qui deviennent déjà très très importants
des politiciens et tout ça c'est pour ça
que mon père a beaucoup souffert pour
m'envoyer dans cette grande école où il
y aura tous les chefs de l'avenir et
bien ils ont tous quitté il y avait plus
rien il y avait que moi ça c'est la fin
d'Alexandrie et puis concernant les
Américains c'est vrai que vous avez de
plus en plus souffert du mépris qu'ils
ont pour les autres cultures que la leur
et ça ça brise un petit peu le mythe
aussi par exemple j'ai fait un film
formidable s'appelle le destin dans
lequel vous montrez très précisément
comment les intégristes pratiquent de
véritables lavages de cerveau sur les
jeunes qu'il recrutent ça vous est
arrivé d'ailleurs avec un acteur à vous
qui en trois semaines est devenu une
espèce de zombie qui commençait à vous à
vous juger qui commençait à vous
regarder différemment et bien ce film le
destin j'aurais pu ouvrir les yeux de
beaucoup de monde aux États-Unis
personne n'a vu
malheureusement non maintenant j'essaye
moi je parce que si l'aurait vu ouais
comment on fait un lavage de cerveau
qu'on contre lequel est-il ils sont en
train de se battre maintenant
il aurait pu voir les mécanismes de ça
Youssef se mépris cet arrogant des
Américains et reprises en Europe par
Berlusconi quand il parle de
civilisation
occidentale supérieure et vous dites
quand j'entends ça je me sens devenir
terroriste et pourtant au départ vous
êtes vraiment pas un terroriste dans
premièrement j'ai dit quelque chose j'ai
dit que c'était un singe parce que pour
qu'il parle comme ça c'est absolument
illogique
mais d'une façon générale vous trouvez
pas que bouche maintenant qu'il a gagné
la guerre
en Afghanistan vous trouvez pas qu'il
devient arrogant comme il était avant le
11 septembre ah oui ça c'est ça le
moindre doute parce que je connais assez
bien mon
américain mais il y a autre chose qui
est beaucoup plus grave il a dit je ne
peux pas prendre des prisonniers et je
veux pas qu'il rentre chez eux qu'est-ce
que tu veux faire tu veux les tuer c'est
quand toutes les conventions il veut
faire des triburos militaires
quand il y a eu l'attentat du World
Trade Center le 11 septembre dernier
est-ce que vous avez pensé à un moment
ils l'ont bien mérité finalement
on peut pas devenir une mince point
non j'ai dit attention j'ai prévenu que
j'allais arriver et ça c'est très
important pour pour remettre en scène à
savoir
certains signaux sont là qui qui est en
train de faire croire qu'elles sont
discours et tout ça vous pouvez prévoir
un tout petit peu qu'est-ce qui va
arriver moi j'étais certain que quelque
chose allait arriver c'est impossible
cette colère retenue d'une d'une façon
incroyable et c'était justice mais moi
j'ai lu une phrase de vous terrible vous
dites que les Américains défend d'Israël
parce que le Congrès américain est
dominé par les sionistes est-ce que
c'est pas terrible d'avoir un homme
comme vous qui est un grand artiste qui
avait été élevé Alexandrie qui est une
ville comme on l'a dit très cosmopolite
il fait tolérante est-ce que c'est pas
très grave et très triste de voir
quelqu'un comme vous aujourd'hui
se radicaliser à ce point-là non ce
n'est pas se radicaliser il y a
certaines vérités à 80%
les sénateurs et tout ça sont sans
soutenus par
des sioniste alors là ce n'est pas ce
radicaliser mais c'est avoir les yeux
ouverts vous vous-même vous êtes
emmerdez de désaméricains bien sûr vous
ne dites pas probablement assez on le
dit ici mais quand votre président va
pour mourir de joie pour voir Monsieur
les Français étaient devenus des
caniches des Américains
qu'est-ce qui se passe je me sens pas
bien
mes toilettes
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que vous lui avez fait fumer
Youssef
Chahine une dernière question en Egypte
récemment de nombreuses homosexuels ont
été condamnés
je sais pas pourquoi ça doit être pour
cacher un autre scandale on fait un
scandale pour cacher un autre on fait un
scandale politique ou quelque chose
parce que c'est totalement scandaleux et
d'ailleurs c'est pas vrai
ils peuvent arrêter 60 mais moi je crois
que là beaucoup beaucoup plus
vous avez eu des hauts vous avez eu des
bas on va faire une interview à peine
down on a bouge pas
[Musique]
pendant Youssef
que préférez-vous en vous elle a de très
beaux yeux
et que détestez-vous en vous allez
beaucoup de choses par exemple non il me
faut au moins
rallonger l'émission de trois quarts
d'heure c'est pas possible
d'accord qu'est-ce que vous préférez
dans le cinéma
la vérité certainement qu'est-ce que
vous haïssez dans le cinéma
surtout quand on veut faire un lavage de
cerveau à partir du cinéma
nous sommes les plus forts nous sommes
les plus beaux la violence jusqu'à
il fallait pas que ceux qui étaient
arrivés arrivent
penser que le 11 septembre c'est un film
américain non ça va être un film
égyptien c'est mon prochain
quel est votre film préféré en dehors
des vôtres
très peu
non il y a beaucoup
dernièrement la méthode ancienne juive
australien qui est absolument formidable
celui qui a fait Moulin Rouge
basse-normes
quel est le film que vous détestez
par-dessus tout
j'ai pas un film spécial j'ai pas un
film spécial que je déteste il y a
beaucoup de films que par exemple
je me rappelle pas comme ça il y avait
je suis venu en été ici à Paris
malheureusement j'ai été six fois au
cinéma 6 fois j'ai dû j'ai dû sortir je
m'emmerdais
c'est pas le luxe ici
quel a été Youssef Chahine le plus grand
moment de votre vie
peut-être calme
d'avoir des prix à Cannes c'est quand il
rentre en Egypte plus personne peut
l'emmerder après parce que sinon il y a
des papiers dans le monde et donc ça
fait mauvais genre quel a été le pire
moment de votre vie
les pires moments quand il y a eu les
chrétiens que qui se prenaient pour les
directeurs du CNC égyptien des choses là
et qui voulait me dicter quoi faire et
j'ai dû quitter le pays ouais je suis
retourné en plus tard parce que j'aime
ce qui vous plaît le plus dans la vie
la musique
et l'amour
ce qui vous plaît le MOINS dans la vie
votre plus belle histoire d'amour
j'avais 17 ans
il y avait de
l'information
donc il y en avait une qui était
nymphomane déjà oui oui c'est celle qui
m'a dit
ok
il y avait la
campagne c'est pas vrai c'était une
musique fit girl moi je disais mais
jamais elle va me regarder
je m'imaginais pas qu'elle finirai là où
elle a fini
donc ça
c'était la plus belle histoire d'amour
maintenant la plus moche la pire
histoire d'amour non j'ai pas eu de
l'histoire d'amour
au contraire
le problème c'est que je continue à
aimer tout ce que j'ai aimé alors
maintenant ça commence à sympathie un
tout petit
Youssef
qu'avez-vous de plus sexy en vous
je dois faire une démonstration
[Rires]
qu'est-ce qui vous dit
[Applaudissements]
chez moi
quand j'étais petit je me mettais du
scotch sur les oreilles pour essayer de
les recoller pendant que je dormais la
nuit donc si tu veux
[Rires]
dans le sexe la précision
très peu
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
tube abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce
bleu